it doesn't really matter he's that good
on the offensive end it doesn't matter
just pick your poison this time it just
happens to be lebron who played good
defense
but it's a different very talkative very
demonstrative
like another coach on the floor and
james harden you know who's going to win
but james harden is a problem
early on in this ball game which is not
a welcome sight for the lakers
they've had a long time off mark they
haven't played since last saturday
whistle foul
and one this time danny green trying to
do it
caruso blocking foul and one davis
matched up against harden on the switch
now they double them westbrook attacks
from the slot and gets the layup
who's not going to have his hands full
here harden with the three
doing what james harden usually does
step back fall back
splash
[Music]
great anticipation by hardin
and he had to punch that in or else
doesn't get enough credit for the passer
that he is
it's legitimate great point guards that
can't be valuable
he'll go down with you know some of the
best who's ever done it
off the field there will be a growing
appreciation for what he does
covington
westbrook just inside the three-point
line
it's about a six second difference with
the shot clock and game clock westbrook
takes most of the majority of mid-range
jumpers
for the entire team and those last two
went in the basketball gods at work
houston gets it back but again russell
westbrook should think this is not going
to happen
and he drills the three thing
run for the houston rockets squaring up
on one of the best defenders
in the nba butter
harden floater in the paint contact
block
that's not a bad challenge lakers are
challenging it stands it's a 14-nothing
run